if you live in Asia and want to play CS
go it's quickly becoming literally
impossible and valve they might be too
preoccupied to do anything about it
before we get into this absolutely wild
story I wanted to give a quick shout out
to the new show we've been doing in
partnership with Kraken rum it's called
into the dark and it follows stories of
the biggest Risk Takers in Esports
simple Imperial Hal nadeshot and anyone
else who Took The Road Less Traveled and
emerged Victorious click the link in the
description below to check it out
alright now let's get into this story
imagine not being able to play your
favorite game because of where you live
then imagine the developer knows this
and isn't doing anything to fix the
problem
okay that part might not be too hard to
imagine from Bugs to server issues games
being broken or unplayable is a far too
common reality and devs sitting idly by
with their hands in their pockets is
just par for the course but in the case
of many CS go players on Asian servers
they haven't been able to play for a
much more bizarre reason
Bots yes according to a Reddit post by
user Japes the tank some Asian regions
have had a massive bot problem limiting
people from playing in many of Cs Go's
warm-up game modes retake deathmatch and
more have become infested with Bots who
insta-kick players and ban them so they
can't rejoin jape the tank goes on to
explain that eventually this just
happens to every server until there's
nothing left but these bot Farms it's
gotten to the point where even if you
join a brand new server after one round
Bots will flood in and kick all the real
players the user claims they've reported
the servers the Bots and reached out to
valve directly but have heard nothing in
return and apparently this has been
going on for months but why
why are Bots taking over retake servers
what
well there are many reasons why someone
would want to partake in bot farming but
it almost always comes down to XP every
time you play a full match of any game
mode in CS go you receive XP towards
your rank since leveling up your rank
used to randomly net you a case people
would run bot Farms to increase their
chance of getting them but ever since
valve changed the case drops to just
once per week potentially to combat this
XP farming the point of Bot farming has
likely been to upgrade your service
model upgrading your service metal
changes its color and sometimes having
the last one is seen as a bit of a flex
and apparently people actually buy
accounts with maxed out surface Metals I
have no clue why anyone would spend
money on something like this but if
people are willing to I can understand
why it creates a demand for XP farming
but how does bot farming even work
honestly I had no clue myself
but then I Googled it and immediately
found a tutorial and the software to do
it it's sketchy as hell but basically
this is how it works you download this
exploit and it joins servers on your
account for you and then acts like a bot
in that server so you don't get kicked
for being idle until the match ends and
you get your XP rinse and repeat over
and over and over again now I'm not too
sure why it has to kick the real players
but I can imagine if you join a server
with a bunch of people just spinning in
circles you would start reporting and
maybe this stops people from doing that
hello team
let's win this game okay
we can do this guys let's go
it is important to know that bot farming
isn't a new phenomenon it's actually
been going on for quite a long time and
it's not even unique to see us go just
ask TF2 players however the degree to
which this Reddit user has experienced
is notable these bot Farms are straight
up eliminating game modes in one of the
world's most popular fps's and sure you
can say it's only retakes but a lot of
people use it to warm up and some people
play it exclusively it's that good
regardless it's just not a very good
look and even though a valve Dev did end
up responding to this now viral thread
they basically just provided us with a
better way to report these instances
however if you scroll through this
thread you'll quickly find out that this
issue is getting even worse this bot
farming problem is happening all over
the world in different game modes of
course I was curious so I did my own
testing some said that flying scoutman
servers and na were filled with Bots and
yes I can confirm every single server I
joined was a bot farm that I was swiftly
kicked from I didn't find this issue in
any other game modes but I'm sure it's a
lot harder to pull off in populated
servers like deathmatch and retakes in
North America the biggest question is
why now bot farming has always been an
issue but never to this degree where you
straight up can't play game modes in
certain regions well it seems like
everything finally comes full circle
because the answer might be
Counter-Strike too it's just a guess and
I'm open to others but maybe with all of
valve's resources pointed at CS2 they've
let some of Cs Go's problems get a
little out of hand valve actually
responding to the Reddit thread could
mean that they're going to try and fix
the issue but hey I have an even better
solution just release CS2
please
yeah like the sleeve goes like super low
which is like the look now with even
just like regular t-shirts
so folks
if if you like that boxy look
if you're if you're a Burly fellow like
myself
bowling shirts